way to go Libs years of brainwashing
young people into thinking they're
doomed over things like climate change
is seriously screwing up an entire
generation
thousands of people are dying you're
going to see more mass migrations more
diseases more severe droughts more
floods Seas Rising temperatures rise
that's what's boiling the oceans
creating these atmospheric rivers and
the rain bombs we have an obligation to
Future generations to make sure that we
have a planet for them to live on we're
like
the world is going to end in 12 years if
we don't address climate change and a
poll asks young Democrats how often
they'd experienced a certain emotion or
problem over the past two weeks are you
ready 61 percent said they felt nervous
or anxious
57 said they had trouble relaxing
and 52 percent reported feeling down and
depressed I never really felt like that
when I was that age no you're a
remarkable person you don't worry at all
so let's just set you aside for a second
because you need depth you need to be
studied in a lab
um ignorance is bliss
the the fact is that a lot of those
emotions but if you yes all of us have
nerves and anxiety because that's how
you live that's called survival and you
learn how to deal with that it's called
resiliency
um but for somehow we have turned this
into a yes we can country to a no you
can't and it's not your fault and I do
think there is an ideological difference
so conservatives for a long time let's
just take um Ronald Reagan right he was
mourning in America Waking Up On the
Sunny Side of the Mountain and so happy
the Democrats and liberals have been
more along the lines of mourning in
America right the Doom and Gloom
everything's bad and bad cells and bad
gets you donations but bad also turns
into this the New York Times reports
today maybe that was yesterday May 1st
mental health related visits to
emergency rooms by children teenagers
and young adults soared from 2011 to
2020 and the sharpest increase was for
suicide related visits and those Rose
five-fold so there is an actual horror
effect to all of this and the school
closures and lockdowns I'm sure didn't
really help Greg yeah but you know I
I
America is seen as a bad place on the
left and the right the left would say
like it's a hopelessly oppressed
oppressive place of racism and on the
right it'd be like this place is
drowning in wokeism I'm one of those
people like I wake up and I read this
stuff about like you know you know the
stuff that's going on in schools I'm
going like man this I gotta I gotta move
to like you know where should I move
Australia I don't know anyway it's so
obvious what it is doing to young people
it's adding a whole layer of
oppressiveness and victimhood then
becomes a badge so they never want to
achieve anything and so what you end up
with are mobs of white purple-haired
uglified miserably uh miserable I hate
to say it mostly women uh and and
they've they're not groomers they're not
Boomers they're doomers they just look
like they're miserable and you know who
did it tick tock and probably MSNBC but
they're deliberately they're
deliberately making themselves
reflective of their own misery it's like
they look like they're unhappy and you
can't help them it's so sad and that's
why I think you're seeing a lot of body
dysmorphia because they're being
encouraged their misery is being
encouraged and they Beca and they feel
like they're hopeless so they'll do
anything and they'll be sold a bill of
goods in this in this weird kind of uh
uh you know uh you know among kids the
trans kid movement it's like no they're
just depressed they're confused is there
a way to help this generation out judge
uh yeah I think uh look they're being
coddled I mean that's part of the
problem they're being coddled they're
being taken care of by their families
they're being told that you need a safe
space and you know feelings and words
can trigger all kinds of emotions that's
training that's behavior that moves from
one generation to the next I mean and
it's learned behavior and so we've got
this whole group of young people who
don't know what it's like to have to
survive on their own sure there are
legitimate reasons to be fearful and
anxious I mean you know you walk down
the street here you might suffer a
carjacking you might get mer you might
be shot by someone on a gang who doesn't
know how to shoot because they've never
wanted to arrange they just picked up a
gun
um I mean there's some legitimate
reasons to be uh depressed but these
kids aren't being taught how to pull
themselves out of it right how to
survive on their own how to be tough and
that's why a lot of the conservative
young people they say it's a different
breed of kid and so you'll find more in
the commas on the east coast and the
west coast and not some much in Middle
America who get on a goddamn truck
excuse me who get on a damn tractor and
work and don't have time to worry about
this nonsense and spend their lives on
Tick Tock get on a darn tractor Jessica
is that the same as a midsize SUV
um
so 18 to 29 year olds and that's what
this poll is covering it would be great
to go down to 13 year olds because
that's really where this anxiety is
starting especially with young girls and
what's going on in terms of image issues
from what they're seeing on social media
and feeling absolutely terrible about
themselves and developing huge mental
health challenges at a young age but age
and 29 year olds share a lot of common
fears a lot of them have to do with
school shootings and growing up in a
generation that was doing lockdown
drills teen anxiety due to our obsessive
emphasis on student achievement is a big
piece of this as well and that's
bipartisan
um so I don't think that bifurcating it
to Greg's point
people on both sides have the opposing
view of how the other one is ruining the
country and that gives them anxiety if
they're that politicized at this point
but I worry that this is actually deeper
than politics and that's more
disconcerting than any of this I get it
you know we work adjacent to politics
and we talk about it and represent
whatever political point of view but
when you think about how damaged these
kids are from such a young age that's
before they even know what a policy
position is that they like they just
know that they feel ugly but they are or
they know that their polar bears are
going to have to swim forever because
there won't be any icebergs
that maybe Al Gore is what they see
before they go to bed at night
I doubt it I wonder Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now